[Musique]
cette semaine a eu lieu un peu geek je
sais pas si vous avez suivi la
présentation par au pot de trois
nouveaux smartphones
il ya le haut pour raynaud que le modèle
6,4 pouces et il ya le haut pour raynaud
avec un zoom x 10 eyal au port et no 5 g
ça fait trois nouveaux smartphones du
côté sur pau c'est une toute nouvelle
gamme alors malheureusement j'ai pas pu
être à la présentation simplement parce
que j'étais retenu
donc je ne pouvais pas y être cette
semaine je vous pose cette présentation
c'est sur le au nord 20 light
alors on mord pas eu de tous ces
smartphones prochainement on va se
tester tous les deux donc vous pouvez
dès maintenant vous abonner comme ça
vous serez tous mes mais pense qu'il ya
toujours un mais j'ai mon pote suisse
dessus ici mr parier qu'ils étaient
présents à l'événement qui m'a fait
plein d'image merci à lui ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je laisse à mon pote
musset jours fériés vous parlez très
très très rapidement et ensuite je vous
présente ses smartphones
[Musique]
bienvenue en suisse
envoyé spécial perrier pour vous servir
bon il est temps de prendre le train
pour aller à zurich est la plus grande
ville de suisse là bas va s'y dérouler
la conférence de au pot on va connaître
enfin leur nouveau smartphone
[Musique]
avec moi la plage calais derrière là on
est situé à mi chemin entre séville en
espagne faro au portugal c'est [ __ ] ou
briand 6 accent il pas trop mauvais je
suis là pour quelques jours pour l'ief
un il fasse un salon qui a lieu à berlin
tous les ans début septembre
là on est sur un événement presse
quelques mois avant de lever 300
journalistes qui viennent du monde
entier pour parler un peu de ce qui va y
avoir des techno a réveillé les
entreprises à passer un truc assez
intéressant et je vais aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas vous parler ça aujourd'hui je
vous parlais dans ce parti qui a été
présenté il ya quelques jours par paul
piché ici mais antisèches je vais
essayer de décrypter un peu quels sont
ses smartphones qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec
alors déjà pour décrocher sa il ya trois
smartphones il y en a un qu'on va
éliminer par défaut sereno 5 g même s'il
est bien même s'il est assez haut de
gamme aujourd'hui mises à part quelques
pays la 5g n'est pas encore arrivé
notamment en france dont pour l'instant
on va l'oublier
elle va arriver en suisse ça peut être
intéressant si vous êtes suisse si vous
êtes fils david haye aureilhan la chaîne
de mon pote mr paris qui est vraiment
très très bien ce smartphone on le met
de côté vous avez un autre personne qui
est intéressant c'est celui avec un zoom
x 10
zoom périscopique ça ça c'est
intéressant ils ont déjà parlé d'une
périscopique avec celui là avec le web
et 30 pro vraiment ce qui était
intéressant j'ai vraiment hâte de
pouvoir tester la solution de au pot on
en reparlera dans quelques jours et il
ya le modèle plus d'entrée de gamme qui
est intéressant c'est le reno dont 60
sur le créneau raynaud de base et le
réno avec le zoom x 10
yann c vent ici j'ai passé trop
dérangeant vous me le dirait en bas en
commentaire je sis à 30 ans vous allez
avoir alors déjà au niveau de l'écran ce
qui est cool c'est que au niveau du
design vous avez un smartphone avec un
grand écran une caméra qui va se cacher
qui est une caméra qui est qui sort
comme espèce de couteau suisse
c'est assez drôle lui qui a été présenté
en suisse a justement c'est assez
marrant alors vous avez ce que j'appelle
un écran panoramique sur le modèle avec
le zoom x 10 2 un écran 6,6 pouces
tandis que sur le modèle raynaud vous
avez un écran de 6,4 pouces 2340 par
1080 pixels dans les deux cas vous avez
un format 19 points 5/9 un écran qui
occupent 93,1 % et la face avant c'est
très grand c'est bien on a pas
d'encoches ça c'est cool on a un tout
petit bar au menton un peu plus grand
mais franchement c'est pas grand chose
en bas des petites bandes noires sur les
côtés
c'est assez sympa et en plus de ça il
est protégé avec un corning gorilla
glass 6 donc résistant et ça c'est
plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
il m'avait manqué de vous parler d'un
sujet comme ça au bord de l'océan parce
qu'ici on dépend méditerranée
malheureusement fin malheureusement
spada là on est quand même très bien
loïc n'êtes pas trop trop froide
franchement j'ai pas trop à me plaindre
regardez là et bien ça va
alors justement je vous prête une petite
caméra parce que c'est vraiment la
nouveauté on voit que les caméras
rétractable caméra a movie sein vient de
plus en plus pour qu'on les des des
écrans de plus en plus large
de plus en plus grand c'est vraiment la
grande tendance toute façon c'est là
dessus qu'on va aller on va très très
très clairement là vous avez une caméra
pivotante qui s'ouvre sur une partie
avec un angle de attendez j'ai langue-là
avec un pivot de 11° sommes à ces
mignons c'est pas mal ça vous fait une
caméra de 16 mégapixels ouverture de f
2.0 vous avez plein de modes dessus vous
avez notamment de l'ultra night mode 2.0
pour les photos de nuit ça c'est plutôt
cool truc qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est une caméra qui s'ouvre en moins
d'une seconde 0 10,8 secondes pour être
très précis sein peut avoir un sens on
peut faire un seul fil rapide
lorsqu'on veut déverrouiller son
smartphone rapidement tout en assurant
le général lors des phases de tests très
très très très prochainement
et alors rassurez vous un tour tendance
à se dire qu'il ya des parties
mécaniques comme ça je me mette en doute
le fait dans tout cela vous dérange pas
on a toujours tendance à se dire quand
on fait des dans des parties mécaniques
que ça peut craindre ça pourrait être
fragile là cet est testé plus de 200
mille fois on repose donc normalement on
devrait être tranquille ça vous fait
sans ouverture par jour pendant 5 ans je
vous laisse faire les calculs précis ces
données par l'anac donc normalement on
devrait plutôt pas mal en plus si un
enfant qui est relativement intéressant
c'est que si smartphones la caméra est
ouverte et que vous le faites tomber
eh bien il ya un système qui va
reconnaître la chute et qui va refermer
la caméra aussitôt ce qui fait qu'il va
pas s'éclater partir comme une grosse
bouse vous allez être tranquille ça
c'est aussi bien parce que c'est pas non
plus par trump qui sont cadeau cadeaux
j'étais en train de me dire que c'est
mon fils qui serait heureux ici avec
tous les coquillages quel sens la plage
ça serai le plus heureux du monde qui
adore chasser les coquillages là c'est
pas si vous voyez il ya de quoi faire
salut c'est moi
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à l'arrière de
ce smartphone parce que ça c'est un
point quand même relativement essentiel
parce que il ya une caméra à l'avant
c'est bien qu'il ya trois caméras
l'arrière alors sur le modèle avec
l'appareil photo est le zoom x 10 que
vous avez en caméra principale à ses
camarades 48 mégapixels qui arrivait
cette année c'est la 1ère équipe et le
honor view vince et la sony yannick 186
vous passez un tollé côté technique
c'est une caméra qui permettra d'être
excellentes en photos de nuit qui as tu
permets de revenir 4 pixels en en gros
vous avez 48 mégapixels que vous avez
transformé en 12 mégapixels quatre gros
pixels vous faire un seuil d'un pixel
pour capter plus de lumière c'est plutôt
pas mal ça marche bien c'est intéressant
donc ça c'est bien pour les photos de
nuit ça vous permet d'aller chercher un
peu plus loin d'aller zoomer dans
l'image et cette caméra elle ouvre à f
1.7 pour plutôt cool en faible
luminosité à côté de ça vous avez un
ultra grand-angle de 120 degrés sur une
caméra de 8 mégapixels et un tel
objectif de 13 mégapixels
l'idée du point de vue logiciel sait que
les différentes caméras vont travailler
ensemble dans travailler de concert pour
pouvoir vous permet d'avoir ce zoom
hybride x 10 donc l'idée c'est que
lorsque vous êtes loin que vous menez ou
mais vous avez du zoom optique 12x méric
toutes les caméras bosse ensemble et
vous avez résultat qui est hyper hyper
hyper performant qui est hyper cool et
c'est vraiment ça qui va donner la
beauté et le côté réussi à vos images ça
bien sûr on va le tester j'ai vraiment
hâte de voir de quelle manière pour
l'intégrer à mon avis ça va être
vraiment vraiment vraiment intéressant
et sur le modèle je dirais d'entrée de
gamme qui est pas un modèle badiane sur
lorenzo vous avez toujours cette fameuse
sony et mixant 186 l'a48 mégapixels donc
exactement les mêmes caractéristiques
plus une caméra de 5 mégapixels qui va
venir en renfort pour les faits évoqués
donc ici pas de zoom hybride x 10 je
dirais qu'on vient acheter ce modèle là
lorsqu'on veut un smartphone avec cette
fameuse caméra rétractable qu'on veut un
très très grand écran de très bonne
qualité pour visionner à priori carrière
d'être toi de très bonne qualité c'est
un écran oled je sais pas si je voulais
juste avant pour venir visionner du
contenu multimédia mais qu'on veut pas
forcément aller loin en termes de photos
pour en faire des photos de bonne
qualité mais qu'on veut pas non plus un
truc qui déchirent alors y'a un truc r&d
vachement intéressant du point de vue du
design c'est que les caméras ont l'air
d'être bien intégrés directement aux
smartphones à savoir qu'elles sont
cachés sous divers elles sont intégrées
en tout cas au mieux a priori on devrait
pouvoir les toucher et ne pas les voir
avec un petit relief ce qui est pas mal
lorsqu'on pose de ce prêt en tout cas
sur une table ça évite qu'ils soient un
petit peu bancal et on a un corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière pour le
protéger contre les rayures contre 6
contre ça
un smartphone assez résistantes côté
vidéo peut filmer en 4k jusqu'à 60
images par seconde
et qu'en est il de la performance on a
deux possibilités sans modèle 5g sur le
modèle avec le zoom x 10 vous avez un
qualcomm sa dragonne 855 8 gigas de ram
et 256 go de stockage extensible grâce à
une carte microsd tandis que soient
modérés nous vous devez un qualcomm sa
dragonne 710 si giga de ram et 256 giga
de stockage non extensible côté
autonomie c'est pareil vous avez deux
possibilités sur le modèle 5 g / modèle
avec le zoo hybride police vous avez une
très grosse batterie 2 4065 millions
père heures palais ce que sur le modèle
raynaud vous avez une batterie de trois
mille sept cent soixante cinq millions
perreur tout ça avec de la recharge en
usb tilt c'est avec de la recharge
rapide ce système vous qu en gros c'est
de l'art charges extrêmement rapide
c'est le vous qui flashent charge 3.0
c'est dur à dire en gros c'est comme si
vous mettiez deux tuyaux pour le
recharger savoure charge deux fois plus
rapidement c'est vraiment très très
efficace
il tourne sur color os 6 et le tout
nouvel os de au pot qui est basé sur
android 9 paille alors ça on pourrait
être amené à le regarder en le testant
sera peut-être même une vidéo un parc
sur ce nouveau colère color os6 trajet
du mage articule mal aujourd'hui c'est
difficile ça ça peut aussi être un poids
qui relativement intéressant de voir un
os qui évolue donc ça effectivement
avoir également lors des phases de test
on a du bluetooth 5.0 sur les deux
modèles on a une prise jack uniquement
sur le reno on a du dolby et moss cette
fois ci uniquement sur le réno avec le
zoom x 10 dans tous les cas on a un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé sous l'écran à voir également la
rapidité au pot nous annonce comme étant
rapide
on verra ça également content on va le
tester on a gps bi fréquence pour le
modèle avec le zoom x 10 il est dispo
dans deux couleurs en noir et en verre
et quant aux tarifs je les ai juste ici
le modèle raineau i dispo à 499 euros à
partir du 10 mai prochain d'ailleurs qui
est déjà en précommande si vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description pour aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
lorenzo avec le zoom x 17 à 799 euros
sera disponible début juin tandis que le
modèle 5 et au tarif de 899 euros
alors pour les suisses ça peut valoir le
coup pour d'autres pays peut-être pour
la france très clairement pas du tout si
vous intéresse est disponible à partir
du mois de mai qu'est ce que vous pensez
ce smartphone est ce que vous avez être
content est oui non vous marquez tout ça
en commentaire l'ajout domaine on a une
excursion tout à l'heure c'est un peu
l'aventuré ne sait pas où on va aller je
sais pas ce qui va se passer mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que vous emmène avec moi
dans les moments de la journée on est
parti visiter la caravelle de christophe
colomb elle a été reconstituée lé voyez
juste là donc là vous avez la santa
maría la niña l'ania est là bas je sais
plus comment s'appelle l'autre
s'intéressant donc voilà derniers
moments de la journée je vous emmène sur
un petit coucher de soleil vous allez
voir c'est très sympa très joli on est
ici au sud de l'espagne en andalousie
c'est magnifique
regardez-moi se coucher de soleil est-ce
que c'est pas juste incroyable c'est
juste chouette voilà merci à vous je
vous invite à me dire ce que vous pensez
une fois de plus de ce smartphone yop
auréolé o correio directement en bas en
commentaire vous donne rendez vous dès
demain
d'ici là soyez sages vous embrasse et à
demain ciao